(buzzing)
- I'm James Davis back
with another Swagasaurus.
Do you guys know what a thot is?
Well I'm not talking about
those ideas in your head.
A thot is a hoe.
The word thot is
actually an acronym for
that hoe over there.
A thot is someone who's
hoeing so much out here
in the streets that even
if your face to face
with this individual,
someone across the street
or driving by is calling
them that hoe over there.
Moving forward, if you're
hanging with the cool kids
or you want to sound cool
in front of your coworkers
use the word thot
to describe somebody
who everybody knows
is getting around.
Now if you're describing
multiple hoes over there
then you would use
the term thotties.
I don't know who the
original thot was
maybe Marilyn Monroe, I'm
sure some of the Kennedys
were calling her a thot.
Maybe it's Will Chamberlin,
the NBA Hall of Famer
who once scored 100
points in the game
and also claimed to have
slept with over 20,000 women.
20,000?
He was a trailblazer
in the thot community.
He was getting it in,
he was getting it in.
There's even a famous
family full of thots
that we keep up with.
If you see what I'm saying.
At the end of the
day, respect yourself.
You don't want to end up
in a game of thot potato.
You don't want someone like
me calling you a thot pocket.
It happens.
So ladies and gentlemen
keep it together.
Wrap it and tap it and
hold back the beast.